my name is katrina balff i am in belfast
the movie and here are some tricks of
the trade
to nail a belfast accent well first
thing you have to learn is how to say
bitey and that means how are you but how
do i even talk to you i think you have
to learn to speak really fast because
everybody talks really fast like this if
they did get there they didn't get to
the moon it's not what it says here just
remember to sing song everything you say
they did now we have to cut things out
of the papers and explain how they got
there
[Music]
music's a huge one with this project
actually ken had sent a playlist of some
songs i like to sometimes read something
from that time period or watch some
films and that was also because film was
such a big part of this i like to do
things like each of my characters wears
a different perfume
perfume didn't feel like it should have
been in belfast in the 60s that little
bit of glamour brought her to life for
me and she just felt really familiar
[Music]